I just wanna dance with you
Let the whole world
melt away
And dance with you
Who cares
what other people say
And when we're through
No one can convince us
we were wrong
All it takes is you and me
And a song
Gotta close your eyes.
Close your eyes.
It takes a few seconds.
Oh my goodness!
Open, open, open!
What is it?
-Dinosaurs.
-Where?
You don't see
all these dinosaurs?
Look around.
Look at all these dinosaurs.
You see 'em?
Yeah!
Hey, come on,
come on, come on.
-Wait, watch out!
-What is it?
Don't step in the fire,
we're cave men.
We need this fire
'cause there's
no electricity
and it's cold
out here, okay?
-Watch out, watch out!
-Oh, my good-- a T-rex!
That's a T--get your stuff.
Get your stuff. Get, get it!
We gotta find
some place safe.
-Like what?
-We need a cave.
A cave?
We gotta find a cave,
come on.
-Okay.
-Come on, come on.
Hey, Vivian. Vivian.
Wait, wait.
Look, it's fine, okay.
I was just confused.
You don't have to run
out of your car about it.
I like you.
A lot. I do.
I don't know.
Got all in my head about it
and then I started worrying
that maybe I shouldn't
come off too strong.
You know, you're like this
super powerful feminist
and not just a cute girl.
I mean, you are a cute girl,
don't get me wrong--
There it is.
It's my old duffel coat.
Actually, it was mine first.
Well, long before that
it was mine.
-Oh, was it Mr. Brown?
-Really?
He wore it
on his first day at school.
It's lovely!
Wooden buttons
for ease of paw,
these two
sandwich compartments
are an excellent idea.
I must say,
it suits you very well.
I never thought I'd like
a human coat, but...
You look like
one of the family.
These hallways are murder.
I'm Ellie Chu.
Yes, I know.
We've only been playing
my dad's services
every Sunday
for like four years.
You're his favourite
heathen.
He can't handle
mediocre accompanists.
Even if they are saved.
Remains of the Day.
Loved it.
All that
barely repressed longing.
Oh, hi.
Who is it?
It's carol singers.
Give them a quid,
tell them to bugger off.
Rooney, don't have all day
to bark at you,
so I'm gonna make this
short and sweet.
Practically perfect.
I love it.
I want my daughter
out in front of the school
in ten minutes by herself.
I don't want anybody--
What?
Too suspicious,
he'll think something's up.
-Cover it.
-You.
-Talk! Talk!
-You! Come on!
3-0-6.
-Talk! No!
-Please.
-Rooney! Rooney!
-Yes, sir, yes?
I don't care,
now pay attention.
I changed my mind.
I want you
out in front of the school,
I'd like to have a few words
with you, by God!
On second thought,
don't have time
to talk right now.
We'll get together soon
and have lunch.
The rules of The Sneak
are simple and thus
Follow them close,
you could steal a crust
-Or a crumpet rind
-Or a pinch of pie
Or the grease from the tip
of a soggy French fry
Crumbs and crusts
and stale bread
Soggy flakes and bin dregs
Any old leftovers
We'll sneak home with us
First find a secret entrance
Keep your eyes open wide
-For a hole
-Or a crack
Or a window with a gap
Just enough
to squeeze inside
Once we're in
we creep around
Tiptoe past without a sound
Keep to the shadows
don't get heard
Whisper every single word
Walk as we show you to.
Eyes up, up, up. Up!
Speak as we tell you to.
What whim
led White Witney to whittle?
Act, think,
be as we tell you,
and you'll become
acceptable wives
and responsible mothers.
Follow the path
of so many girls
who once stood
where you do now.
And just
as we moulded them...
so shall we you.
We don't work together
in the real world, Bo.
You're supposed to be
with someone like Bekah.
What are you talking about?
God. I'm talking about this!
How are you missing this?
Do you not know
what it would feel like
to be with me?
Never took you for the type
that cares what people think
I can't, Bo.
That might
make me a coward, but--
It does!
Willowdean Dixon...
I think you're beautiful.
To hell with anyone else
who's ever made you feel
less than that.
My name is Gabriela Diaz.
You killed my father.
Prepare to die!
Gilbert.
Oh, hi, Gilbert.
It's just a collar.
Come on!
Gilbert!